well welcome back you know my general
view that the world's gone completely
crackers well there was a brilliant
piece written in today's Daily Telegraph
by trans athlete Tina Daniels who says
she considered entering events in 2012
London Olympics after undergoing gender
realignment surgery from a man to a
woman I could have won Gold in every
category but she wrote this was
something I couldn't bring myself to do
while others have worked tirelessly for
the chance to realize that same dream
because of my unfair Advantage I would
just be taking a deserved spot away
it's fairness that my next guest is
concerned about today what Athletics is
looking at increasing restrictions on
trans women but not Banning them
completely from women's sport and
British shot put Champion Amelia
strickler says it could screw women in
her sport her words in her own excellent
piece about this and Amelia you join me
now so I better explain to you viewers
why you sound a little bit American
you're born in Ohio yeah you're British
American you compete for for Britain
yeah you've been a British champion and
shot put in twice and you hopefully will
be competing for GB in the Olympics yes
talk to me about this issue because I've
been talking about this as a man for a
long time yeah but in the end I think
there's a debate that has to be won by
women
it seems to me just grotesquely unfair
that you can reduce testosterone as much
as you like but what you got with Jesus
Caitlyn Jenner is very strong about this
you can't reduce physical size power
body mass all the things you accumulate
in a male body for many years is that
really at the heart of this yeah
um ultimately you know the hormones are
not going to take away that male
Advantage the hormone suppressors or
um yeah it's just it's not going to it's
not going to take away that male puberty
you know there are physiological things
you can't change skeleton sizes hip
angles lung capacities you know
obviously the muscle and some people you
know transition later in life don't they
so they may have trained
as a man for many many years biological
male right and then all of a sudden
decided to identify and the common theme
if you take Leah Thomas a swim in
America or you take some of the
sprinters in Connecticut will be
smashing women's records uh or Laurel
hubbardies in New Zealand uh
weightlifter who transitioned and
competes against women the common theme
is that as male performers they were
pretty mediocre but when they start
competing against women having
transitioned and said I'm now
identifying as female they start
smashing records which may never be
beaten in some cases I mean they're
basically rewriting women's sport
exactly and they're taking away a lot of
opportunities from other women that have
worked so hard to be where they are
um Leah Thomas winning the national
title you know they were they were never
good enough to do that in the in the
mail category now we're near good enough
and you know it's it's really about
keeping women's sport Fair where's he
gonna go this I mean if if while
Athletics are going to be so gutless as
they currently being where they're just
basically sitting on the fence and
hoping this all blows over it's not
going to blow over because more and more
people are now identifying as a
different gender this has become a huge
phenomenon now around the world which
means more and more athletes are going
to be transitioning and saying okay now
I'm a woman now what happens if you are
a high performing male athlete in any
discipline and you see an opportunity if
you're cynical we know they're a cheats
in sport right we saw it of course from
Lance Armstrong to others and they go
you know what here's a way for me to
make myself extremely rich and famous
I'll just put my hand up say I'm female
for three years whenever things earn
hundreds of millions and go back to
being a man at the end of it exactly
what's the top someone doing that it's
happening at Grassroots level as well
already
um you know that's even if it's just a
park run surely that means something to
someone to place you know high enough
and you know they'll never have they'll
never have periods they'll never
experience that you know it it does
hinder many many females yes female
children it's a real issue even you know
Dino this summer said you know I've had
lady issues and she didn't perform well
when she didn't perform well that day
and you know it's understandable what
reaction have you had since you wrote
this piece and went public it was a
brave thing to do I've had very good
reactions I've had a lot of people say
you know thank you from me thank you
from my daughter
um you know this this this means a lot
so much to so many you know women and
and men and you know everyone seems to
have have a really positive reaction to
it um obviously any negativity of course
you're gonna have some um you know some
want to say I'm not even British but
right so they start being racist yeah
exactly and they and you've been accused
of being transphobic which is the
default position for anyone that dares
to raise concerns about this issue you
have to be a transphobe even though
at all right no I I fully think they
should be included but there's a way to
have them be included and not have it
harm female Sport and biological females
competing in the in sport you know
completely swimming they did an open
category and a female category to
protect the female sex and to protect
athletes to have a trans category and
just build that up and just have a third
you know but why not I mean yeah what
what's happening in a moment is just not
fair it's not fair to work and women's
rights are being eroded at the altar of
political correctness that's all that's
happening and people are terrified of
saying this is wrong that's why I really
wanted to get you in and I really admire
you for what you've done it's a it's a
really bold thing have you heard from
the British athletic bosses or not I
have not but a lot of other big names my
peers you know people I'm on teams with
big names people that people would know
these names they agree with you strongly
support me but obviously I think you
know people are scared to speak out they
do not want the label of transphobia
right they do not want their contracts
to potentially be in Jeopardy which I
can understand Athletics is not a
wealthy sport we're not making football
money
um but you know it is important to me
and you must have known when he wrote
this piece that this backfire horribly
it might be the end of your career yeah
I mean that's a that literally it could
be here anything could have happened to
you it did cross my mind um but I am so
grateful for everyone who's reached out
positively because it really is touching
to hear that you know someone's daughter
is looking up to me just for speaking up
I didn't expect
good for you we need more people with
your guts to do this then then this
debate can be had properly and fairly
because nobody wants to be unfair to
trans athletes but I don't think they
should be allowed to just dominate
women's sport which is incredibly unfair
to women born to female bodies just
period just simple period but it is full
stop as people say in this country and
what I'm turning all American and
inappropriate there
um finally one question for you what
makes you wake up one day and think I
know what I'm going to do with myself
I'm going to run along and Chuck an
eight pound weight 18 meters
um this is what you do yes I I was young
and got involved in athletics and you
know I loved I loved all the events but
this one this one I seem to excel at and
I just stuck with it and it's been quite
a journey and you know it still makes me
happy whatever amazing I think it's an
amazing thing to watch it really is it's
so hard to actually move and then throw
something that far that weighs eight
pounds it's just a I could I could throw
it out of the pitbit
Amelia you're very gutsy keep speaking
out uh others will follow you but as
always it takes the first people over
the top to just to call it for what it
is and you've done that so thank you
very much thank you thank you so much I
hope I do hope more people speak yeah
because it's very important this has to
get addressed properly yeah and best of
luck see you at the Olympics yeah many
people you all kind of guts at the
Olympics it takes a bit of mental
strength courage resilience don't take
this nonsense if you can take down the
wokies you can certainly win Olympic
gold I'm right behind you Amelia good to
see you thank you